you know it's a kind of exciting topic
for people
even you know outside of artificial
intelligence iq tests
there i think it's mensa whatever
there's different degrees of difficulty
for questions
we talked about this offline a little
bit too about sort of difficult
questions
you know what makes a question on an iq
test
more difficult or less difficult do you
think so
the the thing to keep in mind is that
there's no such thing as
a question that's intrinsically
difficult
it has to be difficult to respect to the
things you already know
and the things you can already do right
so
in in terms of an iq test question
typically you would have it will be
structured for instance
as a set of demonstration
input and output pairs right and then
you would be given
a test input a prompt and you you
you would need to recognize or produce
the corresponding output
and in that narrow context you could say
a difficult question uh is a question
where the input prompt
is very surprising and unexpected
given the the training example just even
the nature of the patterns that you're
observing in the input problem
for instance let's say you have a
rotation problem
you must rotate the shape by 90 degrees
if i give you two examples and then i'll
give you one one
prompt which is actually one of the two
training examples
then there is zero generalization
difficulty for the task it's actually
your task you just recognize that it's
one one of the training examples and you
produce the same answer
now if it's uh if it's a more complex
shape
there is you know a little bit more
generalization but it remains that
you are still doing the same thing at
this time as you were
uh being demonstrated at a training time
a difficult task starts to require
some amount of uh test time adaptation
some amount of
improvisation right so uh
consider i don't know you're teaching a
class on like quantum physics or
something
um if
uh if you wanted to kind of test the
understanding that students have of the
material you would come up with
an exam that's very different
from anything they've seen like on the
internet
when they were cramming on the other
hand if you wanted to make it easy
you would just give them something
that's very similar
to the the mock exams that that they've
taken
something that's just a simple
interpolation of questions that they've
they've already seen and so that would
be an easy exam
it's very similar to what you've been
trained on and a difficult exam is one
that really
probes your understanding because it
forces you
to improvise it forces you to do things
uh that are different from what you were
exposed to before
so that said it doesn't mean that
the exam that requires improvisation is
intrinsically hard
right because maybe your quantum physics
expert
so when you take the exam this is
actually stuff that despite being
new to the students it's not new to you
right
so it can only be difficult with respect
to what the test taker already knows
and with respect to the information that
the test taker has
about the task so that's what i mean by
controlling for
priors what you the information you
bring to the table and the experience
and experience which is
the training data so in in the case of
the the quantum physics exam that would
be
uh all the the the course material
itself and all the mock exams that
students might have taken online
yeah it's interesting because um i've
also i
i sent you an email and i asked you like
i've been
this just this curious question of um
you know what's a really hard iq test
question
and i've been talking to also people who
have designed
iq tests there's a few folks on the
internet it's like a thing
people are really curious about it first
of all most of the iq tests they
designed
they like religiously
protect against the correct answers like
you can't find the correct answers
anywhere in fact the question is ruined
once you know even like the approach
you're supposed to take
so they're very that said the approach
is implicit in
in the training examples so here it is
the training examples it's over
well which is why in arc for instance
there is a test set that is private and
no one has seen it
no for really tough iq questions it's
not obvious
it's not because the ambiguity
like it's uh and you have to
look to them but like some number
sequences and so on it's not
completely clear so like you can get a
sense but
there's like some you know when you look
at a
number sequence i don't know uh
like your fibonacci number sequence if
you look at the first few numbers
that sequence could be completed in a
lot of different ways
and you know some are if you think
deeply or more correct than others like
there's a kind of
intuitive simplicity and elegance to the
correct solution yes
i am personally not a fan of ambiguity
in
in test questions actually but i think
you can have difficulty
uh without requiring ambiguity simply by
making the test
uh require a lot of extrapolation over
the training
examples but the the beautiful question
is difficult but gives away everything
when you give the training
example basically yes meaning that
so the the the i'm i'm interested in in
creating
are not necessarily difficult uh for
humans
because uh human intelligence is the
benchmark
uh they're supposed to be difficult uh
for machines
in ways that are easy for humans like i
think an ideal
uh test of human and machine
intelligence is a test that is
uh actionable that
highlights uh the need for progress
and it highlights the direction in which
you should be making progress
i i think we'll talk about the arc
challenge and the test you've
constructed you have these elegant
examples
i think that highlight like this is
really easy for us humans
but it's really hard for machines but
on the you know the designing an iq test
for iqs of like a higher than 160 and so
on
you have to say you have to take that
and put on steroids right you have to
think like what is hard for humans
and that's a fascinating exercise in
itself
i think and it was an interesting
question of
what it takes to create a really hard
question for humans
because um you again have to do the same
process as you mentioned which is uh
you know something um basically
where the experience that you have
likely to have encountered throughout
your whole life even if you've prepared
for iq tests
which is a big challenge that this will
still be novel for you
yeah i mean novelty is a requirement
you should not be able to practice for
the questions that you're going to be
tested on that's important because
otherwise what you're doing
is not exhibiting intelligence what
you're doing is just retrieving
what you've been exposed before it's
it's the same thing as deep learning
model if you train a deep learning model
on
uh all the possible answers then it will
ace your test in the same way that
uh um you know uh as
a stupid student uh can still ace the
test
if they cram for it they memorize
you know 100 different possible mock
exams and then they hope
that the actual exam will be a very
simple
interpolation of the mock exams and that
student could just be a deep learning
model at that point
but you can actually do that without any
understanding of the material and in
fact many students
pass the exams in exactly this way and
if you want to avoid that you need an
exam that's
unlike anything they've seen that really
probes
their understanding
you